resources are also stretched in Texas
which just reported its deadliest day of
the pandemic more than 2,800 people have
died from the virus there around 220,000
cases have been reported across the
state hospitalizations have more than
doubled in the last two weeks the day of
ära I was outside South Texas Health
System Hospital in McAllen Texas in the
hard-hit Rio Grande Valley today what is
the situation there good morning Vlad
you know doctors and nurses are telling
us right now they are seeing more family
units and they are seeing younger
patients our crews invited inside the
hospital you see behind me in the ER and
in the ICU right now they are treating
more than 140 kovat patients they're
actually having two red beds right now
to accommodate for their higher numbers
in this packed unit intensive care
director dr. Marco Chavez cares for more
than 20 of the hospital's most critical
patients all fighting to stay alive
most lie motionless and almost all need
a ventilator to breathe he says only a
few are likely to survive in this region
new cases are up nearly 70 percent from
two weeks ago
nurses sandy Ramirez and Jessica Monta
my old work in the hospital's emergency
room which is also full was there a
point where you guys were worried we
can't handle this yes there was there's
too much to do and there's not enough
hands and all you want is to make sure
that everybody is okay and now we can
really stop and think about what's
happening and it's terrifying
we're losing the friends and it just
becomes too much both are also afraid of
bringing the virus home you have a four
year old are you scared about bringing
this home now I do I'm terrified every
day my baby asks me mommy do you have
the corner today and it's hard to tell
them baby I can't hug you right now
wanna Prieta who has coronavirus and
Melania is one of the emergency room
patients describe to me what you're
going through her 35 year old daughter
who cared for her and her husband who
soos died from the virus last week four
days after she was admitted to the
hospital now her husband is also
hospitalized are you worried about him
the Rio Grande Valley is a where I grew
up so it's extremely heartbreaking to
see this happen here
Wanda's two nieces actually now have
coronavirus as well when Juan and his
who actually came to the hospital they
were separated the hospital didn't
realize this after our interviews
yesterday they decided to put them both
in a room together so they can try and
get through this recovery by encouraging
each other
Gayle OH must be very hard for you to
know that area so well and see what the
people are going to just another
reminder that wearing a mask makes a
difference we all want to avoid being in
that situation we're pulling for that
family thank you very very much